all right what's going on guys this is
rob and um
for those of you guys who are new to the
channel here uh
it is thanksgiving week and that means
that i give my guys the week off right i
give them time to go spend time with
their families and
all that kind of stuff because the job
that i worked out before i was a
youtuber i usually had to work on
thanksgiving and so i know what it's
like to have to give that day up
and i know what it's like to not be able
to have that week to go spin with your
friends and family right so
uh because of that on the main comics
explained channel here which is where i
have all my staff
basically working uh they're gonna be
getting the week off which means that
we're not really gonna be uploading any
videos this week
the only exception to that will be on
wednesday for patreon which is the
versus video
and tuesday for patreon which is the
uncensored video and this part i think
is the conclusion
of punisher max uh the slavers i think
is the one that we're finishing up
um and so those videos are gonna go on
patreon but aside from that uh we're
just gonna take the week off here
the next update here is discord um
a lot of you guys who are familiar with
the discord server and who've been
around the server for a while
know a couple different things the first
thing is that the number of channels
that we had was really just kind of
absurd right between voice channels and
we had channels for everything so we had
like marvel channels
then we had like x-men channels and all
that kind of stuff and the result was
that we ended up expanding too far too
fast right we were running our discord
server like we had 20
000 people when in reality we only have
about 5 000 really about 5 200
at the time that we're recording this
video and so what we did is we brought
in a guy named trent who is the brother
of another i'm sorry a moderator for the
discord server derek
and had him basically comb through the
whole thing and trent gave us a lot of
really good advice and said here's what
you should condense here's what you
should do with all these different
different things
and so that's what we did um if you go
to the discord server now you'll find an
updated faq section and updated rules
section
uh you'll have to verify if you want to
actually communicate on the discord
server so that way
we can avoid people who are going in and
trolling different things like that and
causing problems
um but you know it's one of these things
where it's designed to kind of clean the
whole place up right to kind of
do a lot of house cleaning work um as
far as all the old channels that are not
there anymore they are not deleted
instead they're archived and what that
means is that as the channel grows or as
a discord server grows
we can bring those channels back and all
that chat history will be there so it's
not gone forever but it's not lost
forever
at the moment it's just down in the
staff section where nobody can see it um
but yeah it's designed to clean the
whole thing up so if you're familiar
with the server go check it out
um it's it's far more cleaned up than it
was before and it's a lot easier to
navigate so far everybody's loved it
which is always a good thing
um and for those of you guys who are new
you'll find a permanent link down
in the description uh to be able to
access discord server and hang out with
me because every friday
i do a uh i do a q a section with you
guys right i do a q a session
where i just talk to you all for an hour
and a half two hours usually about an
hour or something like that
and answer questions with you guys um
sometimes i give away rob core wings uh
we also have a bunch of different games
and events right we have quizzes that
take place we do versus battles on the
discord server so you guys can
you know battle it out over who wins um
we are kicking around a few other ideas
and we'll actually make those known as
we get closer to when we're going to
release those uh those different
um you know engaging activities and and
so on
but uh but that's what the discord
server is right now now the final update
here and this is the one that you guys
are probably here for
the selling of rob core rings um i
am officially selling rob core rings and
i know i've been i'm probably a little
late on this to be honest with you guys
i probably should have done this years
ago
but the biggest problem that i had was
finding a way to sell rob core rings and
keep up with demand
because in years past if i had announced
that rob core rings were for sale i
would have gotten
hundreds of orders right hundreds and
thousands of orders and that would be a
little unreasonable to try to keep up
with
so uh so if you guys are interested rob
core rings are basically
uh you know little literally rings that
you wear and in fact i don't have mine i
gave it to a fan
andrew when i met him for lunch the
other day but um
these are rings that you wear that
basically identify you as being part of
the rob corbin right so
merch by being part of the rob core i'm
also gonna be having t-shirts stuff like
that if you guys want to partake in that
but um these rings are gonna be sold
uh on a limited quantity right so um i
only have sizes
7 8 9 10 11 and 13. i do not have size
12.
the place that makes my rings are
currently sold out of size 12. so as
soon as those become available
i'll update the store but if you check
the link down in the description
right now you'll find rob core rings are
for sale and
uh and yeah so once they're sold out you
guys will have to wait until i update
the store
make another announcement or something
like that and i'll let you guys know
you know when those rings are available
again so i imagine some of you guys are
probably just going to hover around the
store every couple
days to see if it updates or not um i'm
probably going to do this for
the for the next little while maybe on
like a weekly or a bi-weekly basis
uh and just gonna you know get you guys
a bunch of rings i know a lot of you
guys are
sort of chomping at the bit to get your
hands on some so
um so yeah i just want to make this
update video let you guys know what's
going on let you guys know how things
are progressing
and uh yeah so anyway thanks for
watching guys
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you